is not that great of an actor wow wow he
went there what you gonna do this is one
of the dumbest things it's one of the
dumbest things i've ever heard that's
why kids can't talk
that's why kids
[Music]
he is
he's a good actor he picks great movies
he makes movies better but the skill of
acting the skill is range i don't i
don't agree with that range is the whole
game bro if you gotta be able to the
skill is acting don't agree you bro he's
always an angry black man no matter what
yeah that's why he's happy
there's racism in the world bro why are
you bringing that let me be in gotham
let me be in another world [ __ ] can't
be let me be in [ __ ] middle earth
well i got to be a black i want to see
you i want to see this [ __ ] be
[ __ ] i want to see him be i am sam
that's what i'm saying you remember i am
sam yes that [ __ ] was crazy fire
that [ __ ] was crazy bro what's the guy
his name
sean penn yeah that was crazy that movie
yeah it's crazy wasn't that crazy that
was crazy
but it wasn't like
they were actually going to trial to see
whether a [ __ ] [ __ ] could be the
the owner of a kid yeah
you don't need to go to court for that
why you just go oh look he's [ __ ]
[ __ ] and maybe he can't raise his
daughter
right like the whole movie was like
should we or should he not
well you got to check though yeah but
britney still got her kids say again
britney spears still got her kids though
so i don't think she does be honest with
you yeah she don't got her kids bro
she's allowed to have them she's
making another they're gonna take that
one away too bro
i mean they gave it to k fed and he's
not much more yeah
it's brilliant bro wait they're going to
take her new kids pay for the real world
they got to take her new like off rip
they must right she's crazy
i don't think they're gonna she's not in
a conservative ship anymore they got no
grounds
oh so i think she gets to raise this kid
and [ __ ] it up and then we all just get
to watch it happen this is really sad
man i know we made the podcast sad i
know jeez but derrick was also saying
that not that good malcolm x was a trash
movie what
don't
training day not even close to denzel's
best work that's not that hard of a take
it's not even great
if you're a real denzel fan not even
close what is
i like malcolm x man on fire bad man on
fire is so good so i would hire denzel
to babysit my white kid
so fast bro
like there's nobody on this earth that
will protect your child like denzel
would sex
book of eli crimson tide american
gangster all good movies american
gangsters remember the titans oh my god
remember the titans oh john
john q keep proving my point dawg
yes he is
[Laughter]
what do you mean he wasn't angry on
fences
and the sun was like do you even like me
and then he was like i don't have time i
need to like you
yeah that's awesome
yeah philadelphia
angry great but angry i don't watch that
[ __ ] bro the range in that is tom i'll
do that she's crazy bro i'm talking
about the skills
wait gloria
he's a slave yeah yeah no no he's in the
army
he is a slave they literally yo yo yo yo
yo yo yo that's crazy you think that
he's literally in the army bro like
slaves can be in the army bro can they
though yeah
but they talk about how in life they
were like because they always say like
man people uh you know stand up for the
flag remember the whole colin kaepernick
chicken they were like i fought for this
country and it's like bro plenty black
people fall for this country even during
slavery time
but then they got their freedom but he
was freed but they still punished him
that's what the buffalo soldiers were
using a whip he wasn't that free
that was the buffalo soldiers the black
uh what is it called the black not
cadets what are the black uh battalions
yeah the black battalions they basically
sent out west no i know my uncle's one
of them really yeah he's an actual
buffalo soldier yeah he's still like so
on the rose bowl parade bro he he still
rides he like rides with them they do
the the buffalo soldiers ride through
the roosevelt parade every year
he does that [ __ ] got he got his own
buffalo [ __ ] horse and everything bro
is he like is he like 150 yeah
guys thank you so much for watching that
flagrant two clip but before you go i
gotta tell you about blue chew you need
to deliver the woman you care about the
best dick that you can possibly give her
and the way you're going to do that is
with blue chew you don't want to be like
certain djs out here find out you've
been married to a girl for 10 years and
then she never came no you cannot do
that so get blue chew give her the best
dick you can possibly give her and the
way you do that is by going to
bluechew.com and entering the promo code
andrew and they will give you your first
order for free all you got to do is pay
five dollars shipping again that is
bluechew.com
promo code andrew now go watch another
flagrant two clip
you